you want to be promoted to panelists
please raise your hand
and uh feel free to ask questions
during the talk both speakers said it
was okay
and i'm trying to encourage interaction
in this days of remote
visibility so that we actually talk to
each other a little bit even though
we're on the computer
and um uh if you're
the so you can eat if you want to ask
questions you can either just
speak up or maybe maybe better is type
into the chat window
and or the q a window and i will
intercept them
and break into the talk as i feel fit
and
if your panelist posting to the chat
window please change the default to be
so that everything's visible to
panelists and attendees so everyone can
see the questions
and so let's get started then so the
first speaker is eric diener she's a
professor of computer science at the
weizmann institute for spa
or science uh she's well known for work
in the theory of computer science
especially pcp theorems and hardness of
approximation
and uh without further ado um here
please go ahead oh she's speaking i'll
have her title in front of me but
something about constraint satisfaction
problems
yeah i should have i should have yeah
here it is constrained satisfaction and
expansion
sorry about that okay thank you very
much and thanks for the invitation
um okay so i'm trying a new uh
kind of medium for giving a talk which
is this one note
i'm not familiar with it so let's see
how it goes also a disclaimer is that i
prepared this talk especially for today
so
maybe i omitted stuff maybe you know
skipped some stuff so please do ask me
if anything is unclear
and please don't be shy
and let's start okay so the topic that i
chose
is constraint satisfaction and expansion
uh so let's start by talking about
constraint satisfaction problems
and really what we're going to be
talking about is how does the expansion
or how does the structure the graphical
structure underlying
uh constraint satisfaction problem how
does it affect
how hard it is computationally so
instead of defining csps let's look at a
couple of examples
uh the most well-loved example is three
sets
okay so you have a bunch of boolean
variables x1 to xn and you have a bunch
of clauses
each clause involves three variables and
they appear either
as they are or in a negated form and
this is like the prototypical constraint
satisfaction
problem why is it called this way
because
uh you need to find an assignment to the
variables
so that all the clauses are satisfied
that is the problem here
and it's a constraint satisfaction
problem because
each clause you can view it as a
constraint it's saying that
among the variables x1 x2 and x3 there's
all possible eight assignments are
allowed except for one which is
in this case the zero zero zero
assignment for the next clause
the assignment that's not allowed is the
zero one zero assignment so you
you always pick a triple of variables
and disallow one
one of the eight values i mean i'm sure
we all know this but
i want to set the language so you know
what i'm talking about
another example of a csp is uh
the problem of graph coloring in this
problem you are given
not a formula but rather a graph and the
goal
is to assign the vertices with colors so
you're you're searching for an
assignment of the vertices a coloring
and discoloring the constraints that it
has is that the color of the ice vertex
needs to be different
from the color of the j vertex whenever
there's an edge between i and j
if there's no edge there's no constraint
so every edge here is a constraint and
the constraint says
the two endpoints need to be colored
differently okay so you can see that
both of these are special cases of a
more general
kind of problem which we call csp
you have boolean variables actually they
don't have to be boolean i don't know
why i wrote that
you have variables in the coloring case
they're query they get
values in an alphabet of size queue and
you have a bunch of local constraints
in preset these were the clauses in the
colorability these were the edges
and each constraint looks at a constant
number of variables three or two
and the goal is to find an assignment to
all of the variables
that satisfies all of the constraints
that's the satisfiability problem
we also look at a variant of this
problem which is an approximation
variant or optimization where
instead of wanting to satisfy every
single one of the constraints we're
interested in finding the assignment
that maximizes it satisfies as many as
possible
there might be more than one i shouldn't
have said v but we want to find some
assignment
that attains the maximal fraction of
satisfiable constraints
and you know why do we love these
problems so much
er they capture this mind-boggling
phenomena where locally the problem is
really really easy every constraint is
over a constant number of bits it's
very easy to satisfy it separately
it's also easy maybe to satisfy a few of
the constraints together
but once you try to satisfy all of them
together when you go global
everything the picture changes it
becomes hard
and it's you know very interesting to
understand how
what happens how how does this become
hard
okay uh okay so this is the
the problem of csp
and now i want to talk about the
structure of the csp
and later i'm going to try to say some
words about how does the structure
relate to the
computational complexity okay so
what do i mean by structure okay so i
have this
so if i have a csp um
i can draw the following graph it's
called the factor graph
i'm looking only on the left side of the
picture so
i have a bipartite graph on one side i
put all the variables
as nodes and on the other side i put all
the constraints
as nodes and i connect a constraint to
the variables that
are constrained by it and this is called
the factor graph
and now this is already some kind of
graphical depiction of my instance and i
can ask myself
how does the instance behave complexity
wise
with respect to how it behaves graphs
theoretically
is connectivity or expansion and so on
sometimes we don't like bipartite graphs
so much and so we
we look at the square of this graph this
is the
what i drew here on the on the bottom
corner
where you you put a graph only on the
clauses and you connect the clause
to another clause by going one step and
then another step so you go
from a clause to a variable and then
back to a clause
and whenever you took this step you
connect
these two clauses so you see here that
c4 and c7 are connected
in my two-step graph
so so far all i said is that if you give
me a csp
there's a natural graph i can look at
actually this is not the most natural
thing to look at there is something that
i would argue is more natural but we
don't look at it so much
but let's talk about it just for a
minute and this is the
let's call it the constrained hypergraph
okay the constrained hypergraph
and this i would view is the most
natural object the constraint half a
graph has vertices for the variables
and for every constraint if you want to
constraint
some collection of variables then you
would put a hyperedge on this set
okay so if you have a constraint is
given by
a set of vertices okay here
in preset for example this set has size
three but it can have
different sizes and also together with
this set you associate a little
constraint function which tells me which
of the
local assignments on this set alone are
valid and which are in
invalid so which ones i call is
satisfying and which ones i call
unsatisfying
so this this graph together with these
little functions
this is exactly just a different way to
formulate a csp
and the underlying graphical structure
that you see here is a hypergraph
in in the case of a
three set it's a three uniform hyper
graph in the case of
uh i guess
okay in the case of threeset it's a
three uniform hypograph in the case of
coloring it's a two uniform so it's
actually a graph
so in the case of coloring this this
description
coincides with the graph that you're
trying to color
this is another kind of reason from
or justification for me to say that i i
think this description
this graphical description is like the
correct way to describe the csp
okay
however when the
hyper graph is not a graph when the
arity of the constraints is more than
two so they look at more than two
variables
since we get a hyper graph
it is very hard to analyze algorithms
don't really know what to do with a
hyper graph
when we have a graph we can look at the
adjacency matrix
and we can do a bunch of linear algebra
and spectral analysis on it
and these are very powerful tools
when we have a hyper graph the tools
that i know
uh are always uh start by
looking at some graph related to the
hyper graph okay and one of these graphs
is the graph that we talked about
just just above which is the graph where
the vertices are the clauses and you
connect two clauses if they share a
variable
another way of thinking about this graph
so we saw it just before by saying it's
the two-step
walk of the factor graph moving from
clause to variable to clause
another way of viewing it is that you
put all the clauses down as vertices
and then for every for every variable
you put a click connecting all the
clauses
that touch this variable so this graph
is really like a union of clicks
okay so this is a this is a graph that
sometimes we look at
but it's important to understand that
the reason we look at this graph
is not because it's a better description
of our problem but rather because it's a
graph
and we can analyze it much better than
we can
a hyper graph okay so
uh before i move on to talking about the
hardness and
what instances are hard and so on i just
want to say what is the
kind of property that i will be most
interested in
when i study different structure of
different instances
and this will be the property of graph
expansion
so if you're given a graph with vertices
v and edges e we say that it's an edge
expander
if it has no bottleneck so if you've
never
heard this definition before which i
doubt but still
the way to think about this graph is
that it's highly connected no matter how
you split the vertices into two parts
s and s complement so this is a
splitting of the vertices
there's going to be a lot of edges
crossing between s and s complements so
if s is small
you expect the number of edges to be
proportional to the size of
s i wrote here times d
assuming that this is say a d irregular
graph
so this notion is especially interesting
when the graph is
sparse when the graph is dense it's also
interesting but then it's
maybe less surprising that such graphs
exist
it turns out that a random deregular
graph is a very good expander graph
and there are many other constructions
of expander graphs and this is not the
topic of our talk
but i'm gonna
in the next in the next
10 20 minutes talk a lot about expanding
graphs and expansion and i want to
emphasize that i'm talking at a kind of
a high level so
there are many different definitions for
expansion there's
this combinatorial definition of edge
expansion
there are spectral definitions and
there's vertex expansion and all of
these are somewhat similar but not
exactly the same
and i'm not going to go into details
exactly about these things so
[Music]
let's just understand it to be some
definition that says that the graph is
very connected robustly connected
even if you remove some edges it's still
going to be connected
okay all right so uh
so far what we talked about was just
generally csps how to view them as
graphs
and we defined what graph expansion is
now let's talk about the hardness of
threesat which
we know it's a anti-complete and we also
know that it's not only np hard
to find a satisfying assignment exactly
it's also empty hard
to find an approximately satisfying
assignment that's exactly the
content of the pcp theorem
and what does it say precisely it says
that
the following problem is np hard given
in
a preset formula an instance of result
it's anti-hard to decide i see there's
something moved here
it's empty hard to decide if uh
between option one and option two option
one is that this
instance has value one and option two is
that the value is bounded away from one
it's 0.999 or less
and what is the value here the value of
an instance is
something we mentioned earlier it's the
maximal
fraction of constraints that are
satisfiable so you go over all possible
assignments to the variables
each assignment satisfies some of the
clauses and and doesn't satisfy some of
them so it has a value it's a number
between 0 and 1.
and the value of the instance is the
number that's the highest so there's
some assignment that attains
the highest there could be more than one
such assignment
and this would be the value and the
question is okay you give me some
formula do i know uh
algorithmically to to pinpoint the value
or to approximate the value
so okay so the
the famous theorem says that uh deciding
if the value is one or not one
that's np hard and the pcp theorem that
says that actually even
there is a gap so deciding if the value
is 1 or below 0.999
that's also np hard and in fact you know
0.999 is not even the
right number for 3sat the right number
is 7 over 8
which is also kind of interesting
because
every clause in itself has seven out of
the eight possible assignments
so it means that a random assignment is
as good as it gets
and i'm not going to go into this but
there's a huge amount of work
trying to understand for different csps
what is exactly the correct
gap and and so on and we know a lot but
there's also
a lot we don't know in there but this is
not going to be the topic of this talk
however if you don't care so much about
the exact gap
then the pcp theorem tells you that for
many many different csps for coloring
for 3sat and many other examples
you get some gap immediately
because you can do some kind of gadget
reduction between that
so uh before i continue um not i don't
have a good sense of
what the participants here know and so
on so if there's any
questions or please ask me
i don't have to take it that i'm going
too slow or not but okay
uh all right so
np hard instances uh
to start with we don't know what they
look like but i want to talk a little
bit about what kind of instances
come out of the proof of the pcp theorem
okay thanks so
uh to do that i want to look a little
bit at the
proof of the pcp theorem and see how the
proof goes and then we can look at the
structure
of the instances that uh that come out
because the proof of the pcp and what
does it do
it's a reduction so you start out with
an instance you don't know anything
about
it's an np-hard instance and then you
encode it and change it and you get a
new instance
where now you have a gap so previously
you didn't you only knew that either the
value is one or it's not one and that's
empty hard
and after this algorithm that is part of
the proof
you get a new instance that now has this
gap either the value is one or it is
much smaller
like 0.99 so there's two different
proofs for this theorem the first one
this is the
proof the original proof is the
algebraic proof and what it does is it
takes the instance i
drew it here in blue and it you in you
embed it or you encode it in some
algebraic
space okay and you embed it inside a low
degree polynomial over some
a finite field vector space
and then you break it into pieces by
looking at the restriction of this
polynomial to various
lines okay so i'm just saying it in very
high level
so basically you encode your instance in
a polynomial and then you look at its
restrictions to various lines
and then you need to do some more
argumentation
and an important part of this
argumentation is that you look at this
graph where the vertices
are the lines all the different lines so
you know
this line this line this line and you
connect two lines if they intersect so
these are lines in high dimensional
space they don't always intersect
and you rely on the expansion of this
graph
so uh in some sense expansion appears in
this proof
but it's less visible the expansion is
much more visible
in the second proof for the pcp theorem
which is the combinatorial proof
so let me show you just in one slide
where expansion appears there
it's somehow easier to see so in that
in that group you start out with an
instance it's even more convenient
instead of thinking of preset to think
of coloring so you start off with a
graph
that you know either it's perfectly
colorable or not
in the case of not it means that no
matter how you color the vertices
there's going to be at least one edge
that has the same color on both
endpoints
and you slowly convert it into a
different graph and then to a different
graph and repeat it
repeat this until in the end you get a
graph
so that no matter how you color it at
least one percent of the
edges will see the same color so how do
you do this conversion so let's see one
step
in one step you take this graph and now
for every vertex
you look see this vertex you look not
only at this vertex
but also at all of its neighbors and you
create a new a
big vertex for this whole neighborhood
okay and also for each one of these
vertices and their neighbors you create
a bigger vertex that whose value encodes
the entire neighborhood
and now uh since if you assume that this
initial graph had some expansion in it
which we do by some kind of
not easy tricks then
you see that the new graph is more
connected and if there was some problem
it kind of is no no people notice it
even from
further away so somehow the problem gets
amplified and amplified because of the
expansion
of the graph uh so okay so to summarize
this
and then you you kind of keep repeating
and every time you do this
simplification step
you rely on the expansion the edge
expansion of the graph
to show that your gap grew larger
okay so uh what is the conclusion of
this the conclusion is that
in this uh in this theorem in this two
different proofs you see expansion
inside the proof somehow expansion
helps us in these proofs to amplify the
hardness of an instance
so the instance we get at the end of
this theorem the instances that are hard
to approximate
will always have some kind of expansion
as far as i
i know okay
i guess that's it for this one
okay
so so far we talked about worst case
instances
you're here to ask a question please
yeah it's been a long time
since i've looked at your proof that
you're just uh outlining on the previous
page
and i was just wait can you remind can
you remind me how big is the expansion
that you start with before you start
this procedure
in the graph in the first graph g you
start with how big is it
okay first of all thank you for asking a
question maybe other people will also
feel comfortable to ask so you start off
with one graph g
and then you do some kind of
amplification step and you get a new
graph g
and the way the and you keep going like
this
i guess
logarithmically many times and
the way the proof is currently phrased
even the initial graph g is already an
expander
already expander but how is it an
expander
in a trivial way you take your graph g
which you don't know anything about
and you just take an expander off the
shelf and you just kind of
add these edges these are like free
edges they're not real constraints
they're like free constrained
okay and then slowly these constraints
merge with the other constraints so good
yeah
okay yeah good that's what i was asking
thank you of course
just to comment this proof is inspired
and similar from
both the zigzag construction of
expanders where and
even more from rheingold's proof of the
sl
equals l where he starts with a graph
and he slowly
changes it so that in the end it becomes
an expander but he
he cannot do this silly trick of
overlaying an expander so
it's possible that also in this proof
you don't need to do this
this step it just makes your makes the
proof's easier
so but there are these proofs where the
expansion grows in a more a
moderate way but anyway okay
okay so uh
now in this slide i want to talk about
so
i would love to be able to say there is
some kind of
a scale or a where i can put the
non-expanding on one side they're very
expanding on the other side and i can
understand the complexity as a function
of the
expansion of course i don't really
have such a beautiful picture but let me
just tell you what we know
so far so i don't know why i put this
this is not relevant so so far
we know we saw that the pcp instances
these are like np hard instances are
somewhat expanding
so if this scale talks about how
expanding is your graph
starting from the most non-expanding and
all the way to the very extremely
expanding
i want to draw on the on the
upper on the top the hard instances and
in the bottom the easy instances
so we know that pcp instances are
somewhere
somewhere in the middle and we also know
it's kind of trivial that highly
disconnected instances are easy
right like if each clause involves
completely different variables of course
it's easy to solve your
three sets and in general if your
instance
is consists of small connected
components you can solve each connected
component
even in time that's exponential in the
size of this component so that's
highly disconnected instances are very
easy it doesn't even have to be
completely disconnected as long as you
can partition
a your graph into a lot of small parts
and have a few crossing edges you'll be
able to give a
decent approximation to the value of
this instance
and this will be easy okay so that's
a kind of the simple things that we know
and what other instances do we know and
what do we know about their
about their structure so the next kind
of instances i want to talk about
are random instances okay i'm sure
i think i saw that some we this
lecture series had some lectures about
this
so um let's talk about random instances
so in the case of random instances let's
focus first on three sets
okay so in the case of random instances
what kind of hardness do you expect so
one kind of hardness is when you're
given two distributions so
d no is a distribution of instances
where
i expect the algorithm to see the
instances and say no
it's unsatisfiable and ds
is a distribution of instances where the
algorithm is supposed to say yes it's a
satisfiable
instance and uh
the instances that people look at our
instances of random presets and
planted random presets so what are these
just quickly
you have n variables and you start the
randomly selecting classes you select
the triple of variables in
some literal pattern so some string
where you
disallow this string on these variables
and you repeat
this will give you a random preset and
there is a very important parameter
which is the density the ratio
of the number of clauses to the number
of variables this really
determines the diff the satisfiability
of these instances
and what is the planted random preset
it's a similar
situation but when you select a random
clause
you first fix you plant some
assignment alpha some string of n bits
which is going to be your satisfying
assignment and now whenever you select a
random clause you this
you make sure that this clause doesn't
disallow alpha so you make sure that
the negation pattern is random but it's
not allowed to be
the pattern that alpha has basically you
select random classes so that alpha is
remains a satisfying assignment okay so
you get these two
distributions and uh now there are
various conjectures that say that it's
hard to distinguish between these two
distributions
now let's uh
talk about um
what we know in terms of hardness and
easiness so
even though for a constant density so
for the density above i don't know
four or five four point three a random
preset is going to be
unsatisfiable for all densities all the
way up to square root n
so even if there is n to the 1.1 clauses
or even end to the 1.49 clauses
we still don't know
any way to distinguish between the
planted and the non-planted
distributions okay so this is a hard
problem
okay and i would like to say that
these are random instances so the
underlying graph being a random graph is
probably a very very good expander but
let me
put a little asterisk because we will
see soon it's not exactly correct
so this was a three set we'll get back
to it in a minute but
uh first let me so this was theresa
right
now let me move to a similar csp which
we talked about earlier which is the
coloring csp
so we can look at a similar two
distributions for
coloring the node distribution which is
when you just select a random
graph so in this case let's select a
random deregular graph
g and d this is a distribution of
selecting a random irregular graph
and the planted distribution is the same
but
so here i drew this picture you select
a random graph so these black edges
you see here these black edges are the
random edges
and then you select a random partition
this is the green the green lines
and then after you select this random
partition you make sure to delete
all the edges inside each
each part and you only leave the edges
that cross between the parts
okay now you made this graph three
colorable
okay so this is the planted distribution
okay so whereas the
random distribution you just select
random edges and that's it
in the planted you you delete the edges
from inside each color class
okay and now again you ask yourself is
this easy or is this hard
so unlike the case of trisat it turns
out that this is
actually easy so back in 94 alone and
kahale gave a
spectral algorithm to
recover the partition the planted
partitioning or the planted coloring
in this distribution and as i said
before a very important parameter is the
density
for three sat the density needs to go
all the way above
square root n meaning the number of
clauses is n times square root n
before this before distinguishing
planted from random becomes easy for
coloring
already at some constant density the
alun kahale algorithm works okay so you
see very very different
behavior between these two
csps which on some level i view them as
very similar there's a very simple
gadget reduction from one to the other
and so you might find this a bit
surprising
excuse me could you define
planted random 3 set again please sure
so you you want to select a random
preset but you want to make sure
that some specific assignment in this
case it's this
it's this alpha you see here i chose
this alpha
i choose a string on n bits which are my
end variables and i
i'm going to force that this assignment
will be a satisfying assignment
so now i select the clauses and every
time i select the clause i need to
say i select the triple variables but i
also need to select a literal pattern
which of the eight assignment is going
to be disallowed
and i'm going to make sure that alpha is
not disallowed so whatever alpha says
there will will be okay
thanks thanks so i think
if you had to make up your distribution
probably
this is what most of us would uh
think about and so these things i think
are very similar and yet they have
different behavior and i want to try to
understand uh in the next few minutes
why these are different
any more questions one question is that
in the three-set planted distribution
it will be quite biased towards the
to the signs of the literals are going
to be buyers towards their satisfying
assignment
no you know you're right i'm not an
expert in this and i think to avoid this
usually people look at like
not all equal facts so that um
you avoid this bias issue and
and then it you're right you're right i
i don't want to
like get into the details and i'm not an
expert on this but
but thanks uh
okay so what is really
going on here so just to kind of go back
to this
thing here the scale so what we see here
is that
random random coloring
i draw it in the easy case it's easy
okay using spectral algorithm
and whereas random random threesat
is actually hard random it's reset
it's hard for example if if you get a
random threesome
to yeah to know if it's
uh unusual and or unsatisfiable
if it has some non-trivial satisfying
assignment or not
now let me just tell you hear it as a
question
i think you said this already but just
to confirm random three said we have any
conditional theorems about that it is
hard or is this just
we don't know an algorithm ah okay
so conditional theorems know
unless you're willing to say if i assume
that it's hard then it's hard
uh but we do have a concrete lower
bounds
of the form like a sdp
integrality gaps so we know that this
whole family of
semi-definite programming algorithms
cannot they fail on random theresa
that's the best evidence that i know for
the hardness of these things
so let me i want to say a couple of
words on what is going on in this
spectral algorithm
in this along kahalei algorithm how does
it manage to recover
the planted three coloring that we saw
here
and why can't you just take this
algorithm
and run it on the random three set okay
so what's going on is that when you look
at this graph
this random graph the way to look at the
at the graph is often by looking at the
adjacency matrix
and looking at the spectral
decomposition looking at the
eigenvectors of this graph
and since it is a random graph except
for the top eigenvalue which will be one
all the other eigenvalues when you
normalize all the other eigenvalues will
be
1 over or 2 over square would be very
small
okay this is for a random graph but when
you plant
these colorings suddenly higher higher
eigenvalues
will appear and these are eigenvalues
that correspond to
eigenvectors where you put like say 0
here
minus 1 here and plus 1 here
it's not hard to check that i mean if
this was a
exactly balanced partition this would be
an eigenvalue of this graph
if it's not an exactly balanced
partition it's an
approximate eigenvalue and this is the
content of their paper
but from these approximate
from that when you look at the
eigenvectors you can kind of round them
and recover the partition this is what
they do
okay so this looks like a very neat
algorithm
why not let's try to apply it to the
graph
underlying the random preset okay so
first of all to which graph will we
apply it so
hypergraph doesn't have any spectral
theorem i mean i don't know how to
convert a hypergraph
i can make it into a three-dimensional
tensor but then i don't know how to
decompose it spectrally
so i need to have a graph and that's why
we're going to look at the clause versus
clause
graph that we talked before and we can
do that just to confirm
uh the coloring graphs are also
expanding
right yes they're also expanding
but you see because of this
you see this vector that i wrote 0 minus
1 plus 1.
i mean for people who are not used to
spectral analysis
this doesn't look like a vector but if
you think of the vector
of v let me v
in
minus 1 0 plus 1 to the v
okay i guess i shouldn't call it v let's
call it x
okay so i have a vector with uh
[Music]
if v is the vertex set with a coordinate
for every vertex
and this vector i put a minus 1 and all
the vertices in this part
0 and all the vertices in this part and
plus 1 and all the vertices in this part
then this vector if you multiply it by
the adjacency matrix of the graph
you will see that it has eigen a a very
high
eigen value like minus a half or minus a
third i don't remember
but something that is very far from zero
so it's not a very good expander okay it
was a very good expander but then you
removed a bunch of edges
and this vector suddenly came and it's
it's a
it's an indication that this is not such
a great expander anymore
okay so
without uh okay so since
okay so since i'm uh okay
i want to say another couple of things
then let me just say
that
how is the algorithm that works for
random coloring
going to fail for a random three set and
the reason
is that random coloring a
a random uh coloring graph is much more
expanding
than a random three set so if i i look
at the no
instance the graph that wasn't planted
then
gnp is really just an expander whereas
the graph that comes out of the random
three set
is not as good as an expander as you
would think
because it's made out of many clicks
that are
you can think of as randomly placed but
each such click
is in some sense so this set of vertices
that is a click
in some sense it's a set that expands
but it doesn't expand
as much as possible because it has many
of the edges
stay inside inside the click so it's
like a mediocre expander it's not
an excellent expander it's a mediocre
expander and because it's mediocre
expander
when you plant a satisfying assignment
which means you remove some edges
okay so something does happen to the
eigenvalue decomposition but it's hidden
by all of these is but by all of these
clicks
all of these clicks also have this
behavior that you know
they don't expand so well so
we we cannot use our spectra algorithm
to
to imitate what eleni khaled did for the
case of coloring
so this is more like a an excuse for why
we don't know how to run the algorithm
in the case of threesat
but what i told sam before is that it's
not only an excuse
in the sense that all of these spectral
algorithms are captured by these
semi-definite programming hierarchies
and we know that random threes that we
can actually prove
rigorously that random threesat instance
is
full in all of these sdp hierarchies
so if you're gonna
find an algorithm to solve or to do
something a non-trivial on random
threeside
you're going to have to step out of the
sdp hierarchy
framework okay so yeah you can
kind of excuse me
due to a question of albert you you said
that you normally work with
not all equal sub is that more expanding
a little bit than threesat
it more expanding than three sat so in
terms of
uh okay so thanks for the question uh
let's see together so uh the clause
a variable clause graph this graph that
i'm talking about
here doesn't change because this graph
doesn't reflect the entire instance it
just reflects
which triple the variables are chosen
so it doesn't depend on the predicate
however
the level extended graph which let me
define it
it does change when you change the
predicate
okay and in particular it makes
a maybe it is more expanding
i don't i don't know how to answer it
but it's still not
sufficiently expanding so the level
extended so
okay let me just say it um
i guess should i really wrap up or
what's the status of um
i can't hear uh it's fine to keep going
yeah so it weird we had some extra time
at the end for questions so it's fine to
have them during your talk instead
okay all right um just to think what
what
uh what okay so i think we're we're good
so
um let me just say this
so uh in the case of
uh of three sat or not all equal sat
or three in any other predicate the
graph where you just take
oops sorry you take vertices
sorry you put vertices for the clauses
and you connect them if they share a
variable
this is kind of the graph underlying the
instance but
of course it doesn't show all the
information
what does show all the information it's
a kind of a list of this graph
we call it the label extended graph in
the level extended graph
let's look for example here
so you have a black vertex for every
clause this is like before
but now you replace this vertex by seven
uh by seven uh
different new vertices for every one of
the
satisfying assignments for this clause
and here
you you have your seven vertices for
this class
so for every clause you have seven new
vertices
and these vertices are labeled according
to the clause so here
i wrote an example so if the clause was
x1 or x2 or x3 it means that the value 0
0 0 is disallowed so the values are 0 0
1
0 0 0 1 0 and so on
okay and the the class next to it c2
they share a variable this one has x1
and this one has
x1 and in this clause the the value
that's disallowed is
a one zero zero okay so i have all four
assignments starting with zero but the
one zero zero here is not allowed
so again i have seven possible
assignments and then i'm going to put an
edge whenever two assignments uh
disagree
okay for example this assignment wants
to assign x1 the value one
but this assignment wants to assign x1
the value zero so they disagree
so i'm going to put an edge so really
what i have here is
sorry what i have here is all the
all the assignments starting with a zero
uh
conflict with all the assignments
starting with a one so it's like two
complete bipartite graphs like this
and i replace every pair of clauses by
this graph
and this is the label extended graph and
on this graph i should ask myself
it's a spectral behavior
however the non-expansion of the graph
that comes because you can look at
all clauses containing a single variable
is still going to be a problem no matter
if you have
three fat or not all equal or three line
so none of the spectral algorithms are
expected to work in this case
i have to say though that there is some
in recent years there is some work
okay but i'm uh you you can ask me later
uh
about it let me let me instead say some
stuff that i plan to say
okay uh okay so
the the work of alon kahale that i
mentioned about coloring
was like a first work as far as i know
doing this safe spectral analysis
and later this kind of was understood
better in the context of the
regularity limits so you know for dense
graphs
the regularity element tells you that
you can think of the graph as having
a few different components and inside
each component
all the vertices behave in the same way
so it makes the graph
from an n vertex graph into a constant
number of component graphs and then you
can solve the cst quickly
and the interesting thing is that there
started to be generalizations from dense
dense means that you have almost n
squared edges
but it turns out that if the graph is an
expander it behaves like it is dense
so there are some algorithms that use
this to
solve the two csps when i say 260 i mean
like coloring where the csp is really on
pairs
okay and this gives some a thread of
algorithms
a different thread of algorithms that is
connected
also shows that csps are easy
when the graph is an expander in
something even
slightly more refined than expander
something called low threshold rank it
means that you can split the graph into
a few pieces but
not too many and then each piece itself
is an expander
[Music]
and all of these works were about uh
problems that have two variables like
coloring
then more recently people started to
think about the csps where the triples
have certain extra properties so there
is this property of
splitable tuples
and
it's a property that you wouldn't
necessarily think about it
a priori because it's it's something
like saying
it's like a random threesome but it's
even more expanding than random presets
and typically people would shy away from
such a statement because
we always think that random is the most
expanding
but it turns out that here here is a
property that is
more expanding than random so let's look
imagine you have some
threesat and you put all the variables
on one side
and all the pairs of variables on the
other side i'm talking here only about
pairs that participate in some clause
okay and now i'm going to put an edge
whenever the union of
this x1 and this pair e4
e3 i guess i wrote i don't know together
make a clause
okay so you connect a variable to all
the completions into a clause
in a random theresa this graph will will
be very bad because every pair of
variables will only have
one one neighbor going to the left
if it's sparse enough once the preset
becomes dense
then the graph might be more connected
anyway
an instance is splittable if this graph
is expanding and
when this graph is expanding you can
again apply these techniques
like the regularity lemma and get better
algorithms
okay so this is my last step
could you show the could you show the
uh reference again please the reference
okay yeah i got it thanks okay
cool um okay so uh
we talked already about the fact that
random threesat and random instances
are hard for all the
studied convex programming hierarchies
even the strongest ones the sum of
squares hierarchy
this was shown by grigoriev and
these are for random theresa recently
uh in a work we showed different kind of
instances coming from
i wrote your hdx based but you should
read it as
splitable
or let me say related to splitaval i
don't know how to say it
those instances that previously we
talked about and said that they're
easy very related instances coming from
high dimensional expanders
we showed that they are hard so there is
some a very
strange phenomenon going on over there
which
i don't understand uh in these
high dimensional expanders this is a
completely
object that's relatively new is a very
strange object very non-random it's an
object that you construct from a
group theoretic
ideas or number theoretic ideas and it
has this structure that
it has very few triples and yet they
overlap in a very non-trivial way so
it's more expanding than a random three
set
and so on one hand it's easy on the
other hand it's hard
and in all of these proofs you prove
hardness using expansion
but these are different forms of
expansion so
i don't know uh yeah
there it's a story without a a nice
conclusion it's more like the beginning
of a story maybe
to conclude let me say what we talked
about uh
csps and their structure and we saw
empirically that expansion occurs both
in hardness proof
and in algorithms and in hardness
sdp lower bounds it's clear that too
much expansion makes the instance easy
too little expansion when it's very
disconnected also makes the instance
easy
so some mediocre expansion is where the
hardness
happens it seems uh okay but it's still
a long way from understanding really
what's going on okay and
in that end
okay good thank you for very nice talk
let me
applaud on account on part of everybody
and uh we have we have time for some
questions
uh so we're you know we had some
questions during the talk but i think we
also have time for more questions so
please uh
please speak up with questions or post
into the chat window
and uh must be some questions here
um uh let me see someone raised their
hand
michelle you see maybe hell you wanna go
and speak
um somebody raise their hand does that a
question
um
maybe i can ask a question oh i need
someone someone oh it's an attendee
okay let me see here oh i said of course
let me uh that's
good
okay now you're promoted to panelist and
you'll have to rejoin unfortunately so
but he'll be back in a moment
while he's while he's coming back a very
quick question
i don't want a long answer to this but
you mentioned something about reingold's
theorem
um is there any chance of a
simpler proof of the pcp theorem using
his
starting from i mean
is there is is there any interaction i
guess between the two proofs i'm trying
to say here is there simpler is there a
different
theorem based on that that's possible i
think the
gap amplification theorem is very
parallel to his theorem in the way that
slowly the gap gets amplified
um actually
my hope for a simpler pcp theorem is
by using these crazy high dimensional
expander
objects from number theory but i
wouldn't
they would be very nice or simple
constructions but then the analysis
would
definitely not be easy
but yeah all right okay and so now i
think
uh mikhail had a question perhaps or was
it yeah
uh oh antonina has a question at least
what is known about the non-deregular
case
uh question problems that have arbitrary
degree graphs
question okay great thanks so yeah so a
lot of the theory is
a also holds for non-irregular
graphs you need to
when you diagonalize the graph you need
to take care of the different degrees of
the vertices um
but as far as
for so this is more for algorithms right
like uh
in many cases your graph is input to you
from
some input and you need to work even in
a non
irregular case when you use these things
for hardness and
for a lower bounds of
it's rare that you need a non-deregular
graph
i guess when you select the graph at
random from gnp it will be automatically
not irregular but
the degree distribution is very
concentrated
okay
good so if i may ask a question
so you told us this story about alon and
kahala's algorithm how it started with
random instances and then
people started to see what is the
pseudo-random properties that
you need that are enough to get your
algorithm right so
and you also mentioned random threesat
and we had some talks about random
threesome
and there the focus has also always been
into studying the structure of the
solution space
but they always do this thing on average
so it's really a random three set they
analyze the structure of the solution
space
on average so what is the typical
solution so the question is whether
there's some work that
extracts some sort of random properties
that would have the same behavior
like i would like to have for example to
see the random property of
of three set instances that guarantees
that the solution space has
whatever they call it condensation or
scattering or whatever
so is there something like this
yeah it's an excellent question
in particular for example if you want to
use
hardness of random three sets say for
cryptography or some
problem where you want to have a better
understanding of the solution space and
and so on like you want to be collision
resistant so even if i give you
one solution you need to not be able to
find another solution
or something like that so um
[Music]
you're asking do we know of some other
so is the question do we know of a
deterministic
constructions of instances with the same
solution space behavior
yes that's an excellent question i i
don't know
i guess okay the the closest okay the
closest i can think of
is in terms of codes so if the
constraints happen to be linear
constraints you can still study the
the entire thing it will be an
overdetermined system of linear
equations but still
you there could be like a like a random
linear code where there is some subspace
of
solutions and all the rest are not
and there i think also the statistical
physics works hold right that they still
have this condensation
and so on but since we also know of
constructions of error correcting codes
that are not random maybe they also have
okay honestly i have never thought about
it maybe coding theorists have thought
about it and
it's a good thing to think about thanks
for the question
okay good
we also have a question in the chat
window from emery
yoku um i could read it for your memory
if you wish or you can speak up
can you see the chat window here yeah i
can let's read it this may be a bit
unrelated okay maybe everyone can read
so
okay yeah well they just say it this may
be a bit unrelated to the talk but are
there techniques that rely on other
graphs corresponding to c
f formulas i'm specifically curious
about the resolution graph
where each clause is a vertex and there
exists an edge between two vertices if
their clauses can be resolved on a
single variable
could this graph be useful for proof
complexity lower bounds
resolving two clauses corresponds to a
graph minor like operation on this graph
okay this needs to be answered maybe by
someone who knows proof complexity
better than me
i know that the expansion is also used
for resolution lower bounds but
i don't know if it's this graph that is
the expanding one
right it is again on the
clause variable incidence graph in that
case
right yeah
definitely sounds like an interesting
question yeah
okay um all right well maybe we're
a little bit out of time here so thank
you again
very much for a really delightful talk
and uh getting a lot of hand clapping
going on here
so good thanks for the great questions
thank you very much
yes thank you for uh being willing to
speak
and uh we'll take a three minute break
strictly enforced and start at 38
minutes past the hour
um and give you a chance to stretch your
legs if you need to though and
alistair will be speaking just a couple
minutes
okay i apologize to aleister i cannot
stay for the next
hour my kids are waiting but bye
everyone
no worries thanks for the talk